[Music]
from france
knows how it feels to lose george
papandreou from greece has known it for
a long time
and now germany's martin schultz knows
it too
17 years ago socialists or social
democrats were governing in almost all
the big eu countries like france
germany and the uk now they've been
pushed to the borders of the european
union
in france the socialists scored a
humiliating 6.3
in this year's presidential election if
they really abandoned power in germany
italy is the last important bastion for
now
nobody believes them that they really
provide answers
to the pressing problems of the people
um
let's say at the low in the lower income
brackets and
you know basically that's why i think
votes have gone down everywhere
for for them so i think it's a lot about
what social democracy should stand for
namely a more equal society
equality was the hallmark of socialist
and social democratic leaders like
bilibrant in germany
they represented the pinnacle of the
modern and successful political left in
europe
today only jeremy corbyn in the uk
is bucking the trend by steering his
party farther to the left
look on the wall right over there is
that the solution
this wonderful festival
in brussels the party of the european
social democrats
is asking precisely that question and
after the initial shock
vows to fight back
young people financial aid for children
and also
migrants arriving in our countries we
need dignified living conditions for all
people
especially those in difficult and
marginalized situations
we need to be the party that takes care
of the poorest
[Applause]
a stance echoing the left's glory days
with leaders like germany's gerhart
or even the early francois hollande in
france
after the german election they seem as
distant as they ever have
it will take more than a little effort
from social democrats and socialists in
the eu
to get back on track